you
is matt from adam are today we're gonna
be talking to matt and lo the creator of
the award-winning webseries squaresville
squaresville just 13 iaw TV awards two
of them being best comedy writing and
best comedy series we're going to be
talking to Matt about what it's like
being an award-winning comedy writer
working with big frame and what the
initial pitch for squaresville was like
hey Matt how's it going today great
great fantastic so bad for anyone who
doesn't know can you tell us what
squaresville is all about as a web
series and show yeah sure sure so it's a
you know it's the story of two best
friends growing up kinda bored in the
suburbs and we decided to create it
basically because we didn't feel like
there was enough quality programming
that spec spoke to a specific group of
young people you know like so much of
like teenage programming is about like
glamorous kids in New York at a prep
school or something like that and that
really didn't wouldn't have spoken to me
when I was that age and so I thought I'd
make a show for those people now right
right awesome so you just recently 13
iaw TV Awards including Best Comedy and
best writing for a comedy you know what
is it one of those awards kind of need
you as a crater and a writer well I mean
it's tremendous because the iaw TV is
kind of it's a peer group you know it's
it's special like it's one thing like
you know there's views and there's all
sorts of metrics online that are kind of
like can validate whether or not you're
doing what you're doing right but it's
different to have the validation of your
peers and the respect of your peers and
so I've known a lot of the members for a
really long time and it was something
that was just very special to know that
they were into the show and appreciated
what we were doing and could tell that
we were trying to do something new and
different
right absolutely you know there's really
no Academy Awards for web series yet for
web TV you know the heavy awards have
been around for so many years it's been
able to establish itself as the name in
Film Awards whether those are you know a
real award ceremony or not the Academy
Awards as you know yet to be decided but
they are the name in award show same of
the Golden Globes there's no web series
award shows right now that have been
around long enough to establish
themselves as that name right now
there's you know three or four they're
kind of jockeying for that position but
all the longest some of them that around
a three or four years would and I aw TV
award open the same kind of doors for
you as a writer and creator that maybe
winning an Academy Award would or you
know a Golden Globe anything like that
right well I mean obviously you're
exactly right like there's not the same
sort of cachet you know you don't have
to explain what a Golden Globe is to
someone so you know that are they on the
same level maybe you know probably not
however you know that the aw TV Awards
is associated with CES really brings it
a lot of cachet and just kind of you
know that it's you know it's a
legitimate organization they had you
know a press presence and they're
organized and you know you can look at
the voting body and see who's on that
list I think that all is you know in an
effort to legitimize and standardize the
WTB words as something that's you know
has as real clout and so certainly it
has meant it's been meaningful for my
career definitely I had to explain what
it was to my parents and I wouldn't have
to that was an Oscar but uh but you know
my agent is still out there using that
and you know like we're talking about it
now
yes very right so like that has to mean
something you know you know as a writer
are you able to of course you know
you're going to be pitching things
whether that's via studios or we know
web studios whatever as a writer are you
able to take that item you can use a
look at I've won this award are our
executives who are you know very very
frugal and very young discerning are
they going to be able to recognize that
guy this is a really cool thing this is
someone we could trust right well I you
know I think that we're at a very
interesting time in the lab and I kind
of I've been in the space long enough to
kind of see it's absent flows and I
think right now really the crucial thing
is that there's an influx of money and
interest it just feels really electric
all of a sudden so the kind of the way
did you know three or four years ago
kind of really before the economy tanked
so it's a it's very convenient to have
the iaw TV wins while Google money is
flowing in and you know brand money is
flowing and definitely it's helpful but
I think that really it's all about
having you know show that's proven and
that people find interesting and
compelling and that kind of you know
stands out in one way or another that's
what's important and whether that's an I
aw TV award that's doing that or really
exceptional writing or a innovative take
you know there are a lot of different
ways to to crack the studio nut and so I
certainly am grateful that we have the
iaw TV awards but I think that there are
other shows out there that could have a
similar sort of opportunity with it
without that right so right now a lot of
comedy on the web is a single joke
single camera stuff like
raywilliamjohnson or Smosh or shaycarl
do you believe there's room on YouTube
and the internet for long-form narrative
scripted comedy yeah I mean I think that
it's interesting because right now we're
lumping all video that is on the
internet into one category right so you
know it Conan isn't up for like an oscar
for best monologue right Jimmy Kimmel
isn't like trying to vie for like best
pre-roll package right it doesn't make
sense so you know work because we're in
our infants
as a group as a medium were kind of all
lumped together but like what
squaresville is trying to do and what's
a ray william johnson is trying to do is
totally different and that doesn't make
it better or worse than the other it's
just like I'm trying to do a cinematic
character based thing and Ray is trying
to go for hard jokes right that's super
hard I totally respect that and I think
it's more just about kind of letting the
the medium elevate itself a little bit
more and then we'll kind of see you know
separate categories for what those
people are trying to do so absolutely i
believe that like what comedy has you
know a ton of potential at a ton of room
to grow but i wouldn't ever want to
discount what people are doing with
first person to a camera or you know
those jokes are hard to write i don't
think i could write hard funny jokes the
same way you know ray you're rushing
right especially week after week they're
doing this stuff it's pretty it's pretty
impressed yeah oh yeah yeah in the same
kind of vein comedy has been the
standard for web series you look at all
the of original programming big
very major all of these big networks of
you know original programming they're
all basically comedy based the only real
hard drums i can think of our you know
halo forward unto dawn and that was a
whole microsoft you know back thanks
that's a little bit of a different story
do you think there's room for drama
series on the web sure sure well i think
that um you know if you look at like a
show like anyone but me is a great
example and was a big inspiration for us
i think that basically right now the
people who are consuming web content
natively are on the younger side they're
like teens in college somewhere around
there which is kind of like why
squaresville i think is then lucky and
finding it success but as that groove
ages up a little bit they they don't
care if you're watching video on the
internet or on NBC and they're going to
want comedy and they're going to want
drama just like any regular person would
so i think we're just kind of on the the
dawn of that
era and certainly it's just going to get
bigger and better for you right of
course and you know you kind of a
mentioned that there's a ton of money to
tell Google money going into web series
and so a lot of writers who want to
write and want to create their own
things are kind of going to a web as
someone who's had their show greenlit
and someone who's Neil pitch to show how
does that squaresville process work for
you how did you get this show picked up
how did you get a pitch and funded sure
so yeah so we were really fortunate I
mean basically what we had done I'd kind
of come from an old school background of
like let's find the money ourselves
let's do do it the independent film
group way and I just kind of out of good
fortune did a panel with Sarah penna the
co-founder of big frame and as I was
shopping around squaresville we'd kick
started originally I was looking for a
home and I was like oh big frame that's
perfect like they have the right demo
behave they're moving and shaking like
they're the perfect home for square as
well so when we sat down together we all
really clicked I love everybody of that
company they've been tremendously
supportive so it was kind of just an
obvious next step to do the season to
what we could tell that the show was
still really growing that had a really
active fan base it was all the recipe
was there already and it was just like
we need to take it to the next step
basically right so the pitch was you
know as far as Hollywood pitches go was
painless it couldn't have been more
obvious to everyone that we should be
working together more so when I'm very
lucky in that respect and foremost
creators of web series I mean is do they
have to take this indie Kickstarter kind
of mentality where they have to fund it
themselves and then pitch it or do you
think networks are starting to get to
the level where they are willing to you
know fun projects and willing to kind of
take Cutters on on their own well I did
it's interesting because you know web
development and digital studios are
still new so I think that you have to
have with any pitch whether your self
funding or otherwise you have to really
be able to explain why the audience that
you're aiming for with like the show and
why they would be especially interested
and so the reason that I kick-started
whereas those because like you know the
pitch is is not a high-concept pitch
it's not like teen vampires fall in love
it's like out some funny kids talking in
their bedroom and daydreaming right so I
knew that it was execution dependent so
if you've got a show that you really
believe in and you know will work and
you think it's special and you know why
it will work and you put as much craft
as you can into it then and you know
that it's maybe gonna need some time to
find its audience I would say go ahead
and kick start like it's an amazing time
it's an amazing opportunity you know
indie indie fundraising used to mean
like selling floor and rights you know
in Europe so that you could bankroll
your American sales or whatever you know
like all of that old stuff is so far
behind us and it's a cool opportunity
but if you've got you know the rights to
Halo or mortal kombat or something like
that maybe you should go ahead and just
pitch that straight to machinima and you
know I'm sure things will work out you
know so it's kind of like those are the
two vast ends of the spectrum and
obviously most people fall somewhere in
the middle so my last question is can
you just tell us what's next for season
2 squaresville yeah yeah so it I mean it
drops februari first it's it's bigger
it's better it's more exciting episodes
are a little bit longer we're playing
with format a little bit more you know I
think we see further development from
all of our favorite characters you know
Esther gets a love interest Zelda and
Wayne kind of develop a little bit more
first he gets a love interest we learn
more about coach and about Sarah and and
Shelley and Ozzy all those characters
that we kind of have seen floating
around in the background we see a little
bit more of and then we kind of get this
new wave of other characters that kind
of round out the rest of the
squaresville world very cool well thanks
so much for talking about appreciate it
awesome thank you so much
you